what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we deliver
exciting news from the MCU daily I'm
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be diving deep into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and talk about one of the most
anticipated developments the arrival of
the X-Men the X-Men have been a fan
favorite for decades and since Disney's
acquisition of fox fans have been
eagerly waiting for their introduction
into the MCU Marvel and Disney have kept
very quiet about what their plans are
for the X-Men including when they're
going to officially enter the MCU so
today we'll be talking about everything
that we know so far about when and how
the X-Men will enter the MCU now in this
video I've broken it down and put all of
the crucial important information that
you need to know about the X-Men coming
into the MCU into seven key parts and
the first part is extremely important to
know so part one there will be different
types of X-Men in the MCU the important
thing that you need to know about how
the X-Men debut is that there is
basically going to be a line drawn in
the MCU timeline a line is going to be
drawn after Avengers Secret Wars meaning
we are going to see mutant slash X-Men
show up before Secret Wars and after
Secret Wars but there's going to be a
big difference between the ones who come
before and the ones who come after so
who is coming before Secret Wars and who
is coming after well we'll go into that
in part two and part three and part two
is the original X-Men return based off
of everything that we know so far the
primary X-Men that are going to come
before and during Secret Wars will be
the old X-Men from the fox Universe
based off of The Insider reports we've
heard the main X-Men that will fight in
the battle against Kang will be the fox
X-Men and X-Men from other universes not
our main MCU so right now the MCU is
dealing with incursions where two
different universes or more collide with
each other this typically results in the
destruction of one or both or all
universes but we know that in secret
Wars heroes from other universes are
going to come together with heroes from
our main universe and some of these
heroes are going to be the X-Men but
it's going to be the X-Men from the fox
Universe also it's rumored the Fantastic
Four from the fox Universe could show up
as well but the main point of part two
is that the X-Men who show up before
Secret Wars and during are going to be
the older Fox generation of X-Men and
Marvel Studios has basically confirmed
this already with some of the producers
stating that the new X-Men are years and
years away and they aren't going to be
rushed projects which brings us to part
three the new X-Men now there will be a
tiny Glimpse at the new X-Men that are
coming but only teases and not a part of
the official X-Men team this will be
similar to what we saw with Miss Marvel
we got our little X-Men tees with the
X-men theme song playing in the
background and teases like Nemo more and
wakanda forever Kevin feige confirmed
and the movie confirmed he is a mutant
but you won't exactly see him on an
official X-Men team soon the official
X-Men team of the New Mutants in the MCU
is going to come after Secret Wars which
brings us to part four phase seven the
mutant Saga now just for the record we
don't know what the next phase is
officially going to be called but it is
going to be highly focused on mutants
and X-Men specifically starting to put
together the new X-Men team or the
original X-Men team since we've never
had one before in the MCU so the true
new X-Men come after Secret Wars in
Phase 7 and the new saga will most
likely be called something like the
mutant Saga and this Saga in these
phases will work in possibly two
different ways but will ultimately lead
to the same outcome the X-Men having
already been formed in the MCU and them
recruiting new X-Men because we're
really not sure if the X-Men have been
around in the MCU all of this time if
that's the case we're not really sure
what excuse they'll give us for us not
really knowing about them or The
Avengers not knowing about them or maybe
they did but they could go the other way
a new X-Men team being formed right in
front of our eyes for the very first
time meaning the X-Men team does not
already exist in the MCU now if the
X-Men team already exists then will most
likely have characters like Professor X
Magneto Cyclops and other big X-Men
already part of the team we'll watch
these X-Men go and try to find mutants
to bring to Professor X's school for
gifted youngsters and also recruit
mutants for the official X-Men team
however if the team isn't formed yet
we'll most likely start with a solo film
around whoever the leader and villain
are going to be now they could stick to
tradition and this could be a classic
Professor X and Magneto story or it
could be something completely different
because we know Kevin feige wants to
switch it up if something has been done
before Kevin feige likes to mix it up a
little bit he doesn't like to show us
the same thing we've already seen
however the X-Men are kind of an
exception because Professor X leading
the X-Men and Magneto leading the
Brotherhood of evil mutants is a very
big deal because Professor X or Charles
and Magneto or Eric were friends before
they were enemies so there's a big story
to be told with these specific
characters but either way if they're
introducing new X-Men or if the X-Men
team is already established in the MCU
we'll either get movies of the original
X-Men establishing their powers and the
X-Men team or will get recruits either
way it leads to an X-Men team being
formed and an official X-Men movie which
brings us to part 5. X-Men recruits we
will most likely get a build up to the
X-Men team like we gotta build up to the
Avengers solo X-Men projects will build
up to the official formation of the
X-Men team this works even if it's a
combination of new X-Men recruits and
Veterans because it'll still be the
first time that we see the X-Men debut
as an official group on screen it'll be
the project the movie titled the X-Men
even if the team is formed we won't see
the team go into action together until
this official X-Men movie and this
brings us to part six which is kind of
sad but I also think kind of necessary
and that is no more Avengers after
Secret Wars going into phase seven The
Avengers will most likely be background
characters as the focus will now be on
the X-Men and the Fantastic Four this
will basically come as a soft reboot for
the MCU which could come as a pleasant
break for some people but I for one am
really looking forward to a new saga
where the Avengers and the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four are all interacting with
each other in a lot of different
projects and movies and Disney Plus
shows I think it would be fantastic I
think it would be exactly like the
comics where which is what Marvel fans
have wanted for such a long time but
could never get on screen because of the
film rights so hopefully the Avengers
don't really get guidelines hopefully
they still stay very prominent in the
MCU now even if they do get put on the
back line for maybe a saga or a couple
of phases they are definitely going to
be coming back and eventually we'll get
what part 7 is a huge Avengers and game
slash Secret Wars event the next one
probably following Secret Wars that will
have all of these different Heroes
coming together on screen for the First
Time The Avengers The Fantastic Four and
the new X-Men not the fox X-Men in one
event that I think would be really cool
especially since you are now introducing
mutants into the MCU alongside of the
Avengers is The Avengers vs the X-Men
new heroes are coming into the MCU The
Avengers are used to being the super
hero team well what happens when new
people who have actual Powers genetic
powers like the Scarlet Witch come into
play and go up against people like
Captain America Sam Wilson who doesn't
have any powers Hawkeye and Kate Bishop
no powers Elena Bulova Red Guardian
Bucky yes some of these have super
soldier serum but no really mutant
abilities here no teleportation no laser
beams coming out of their eyes no
abilities to produce storms what happens
if these two groups don't exactly get
along when they first get introduced to
each other which I think would kind of
be a cool story arc for them to do do an
Avengers versus X-men have them fight
but you know eventually do the superhero
thing where you have a versus film and
get them to fight a bigger cause then
realizing that they have to work
together they're all super they all have
the ability to protect the world and
people so it's their duty to work
together and of course after that
develop deep deep connections and
relationships with each other that will
last many many sagas hopefully but I
would like to see an Avengers vs the
X-Men at one point in time and something
that would be really interesting to see
if that happens is whose side would the
Fantastic Four take or would the
Fantastic Four be divided as well we're
not really sure what the future holds
Marvel is being very tight lip about it
and of course they are we haven't even
gotten to Secret Wars yet but that is
everything that we know about the X-Men
coming to the MCU New and Old X-Men and
no matter what the future is definitely
looking bright for Marvel Studios and
the MCU with the upcoming inclusion of
the official X-Men team but let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter our giveaway for a
chance to win a PS5 and Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well winner gets to pick and
we're picking a winner at the end of
each month don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
foreign